it's been a very busy 48 hours of uh
targeting across uh ukraine um largely
focused on nickapol vignetstra but
actually more broadly in a somewhat
random pattern but actually either this
is part of a terror campaign
deliberately targeting um women and
children or what's more likely is this
part of the russians making a master
target list and actually attacking lines
of communication and the ukrainian
weapons part of the challenge here of
course is that russia doesn't seem to
always hit what it's aiming for which
has devastating consequences so north in
kharkiv the russians have been pushed
back by ukrainian forces but that
threatens russian lines of supply here
and therefore undoubtedly russians have
been targeting kharkiv to try and deter
further attacks and likewise once the
battle for the donbass is over the
battle for odessa is likely to be next
kirsten is a key stepping stone for that
and on curson the
ukrainians are mounting some pretty
ferocious counter-attacks which has the
added benefit of making russia think
whether it should leave its troops here
or divert them down south over in the
donbass there has been an operational
pause in place for the last few days
allowing the russians to
get their troops and uh refurbished
refreshed and resupplied but of course
that also provides opportunities for the
ukraine to do exactly the same thing and
they've been digging in during the time
what next we're fully expecting to see
the russian playbook which is artillery
artillery artillery
after that they then move the troops in
and consolidate as a result we expect to
see saversk and bachmut cut targeted
first and then move across towards
slovanska and kramatorsk after that the
ukrainians have been fierce in their uh
defense but they have been seeding
ground steadily as this battle commenced
and as churchill famously opined victory
is not born of glorious retreats ukraine
has to find a way of turning the tide of
this war but they are buying time and
wester weapons could prove decisive